bonjour à tous les deux merci beaucoup
d'être en direct ce matin sur rtl france
gilles lazar y nichent commence par vous
vous êtes donc candidat à l'élection
présidentielle vous défendez un
programme évidemment qui prend la
défense de l'environnement je vous pose
cette première question est ce qu'on
peut concilier la défense de cet
environnement avec on le voit le pouvoir
d'achat des français aujourd'hui
écoutez moi je vais être je vais être
direct je pense que malheureusement ne
peux pas j'ai bien conscience que
si on pense à la transition écologique
et à l'environnement cela va avoir un
impact sur le portefeuille des français
je pense qu'il faut être responsable et
moi je suis justement un citoyen
responsable et je sais bien que
on a un gros problème de pouvoir d'achat
en france c'est clair que si le pouvoir
d'achat était beaucoup plus élevé on
aurait pas de problématique au niveau
justement sociale mais là effectivement
s'en est rendu compte il ya quelque
temps avec les gilet jaune et la taxe
carbone dès qu'on ajoute des taxes
supplémentaires comme la sur le gaz et
l'électricité on se retrouve avec des
gros soucis au niveau du portefeuille
national du portefeuille des français
oui résultat les français sont dans la
rue en tout cas le gouvernement qui
craint une nouvelle explosion sociale
georges kiejman au beach en dix ans la
fiscalité environnementale a augmenté de
plus de 55% c'est pas rien
ont d'abord bonjour et merci pour
l'invitation
écoutez je suis pas d'accord avec ce
qu'il ya un truc d'être dit car là qu'on
taxe et on tape dans le portefeuille des
français alors qu'il y à bien des
mesures pour améliorer l'environnement
et surtout préparer la france à la crise
climatique dans laquelle on est déjà je
rappelle que la france est responsable
pour 1 % des émissions de co2 dans le
monde dont de toute façon même si on est
de très bon élève et qu on le serait en
encore plus ça ne changerait pas grand
chose au total mais par contre on peut
faire notre part et plutôt que de taxer
les citoyens
je pense qu'il faut arrêter le tout
routier
immédiatement arrêté le pacte
ferroviaire imposées par l'union
européenne stoppez la privatisation qui
est en cours
d'edf la rupture en petit bout de cette
entreprise stratégique française
reprendre nos recherches dans le
nucléaire en particulier le projet
astrid et vous voyez récemment a été
réouvert la ligne perpignan
régissent
la ligne ferroviaire qui avait été
arrêtée à cause du pacte à cause du
pacte ferroviaire imposé par une
européenne ces vingt mille camions en
moins sur les routes entre perpignan et
rungis une seule ligne donc nous nous
considérons qu'il faut ré ouvrir
l'ensemble du réseau ferré
d'abord ça ferait du travail beaucoup de
travail pour les français donc améliorer
le portefeuille des familles ça
permettrait de dynamiser les régions et
ça n'est possible qu'avec un parc
nucléaire fort et donc de l'électricité
et donc l'énergie très fortement
décarbonée voilà ce qu'il faut faire un
premier lieu avant que taper dans le
canton fait des français alors il faut
zèle elle ça va revenir évidemment dans
le débat un grand un grand enjeu
d'ailleurs de cette présidentielle
la relance ou le maintien du nucléaire
j-2 lazarini on va écouter gabriel at
elle qui a répondu
à yannick jadot justement sur sur cette
question du nucléaire que les que les
écolos veulent veulent supprimer a
graduellement gabriela talent a parlé d'
une écologie punitive et d'un un nom 2.0
rien de nouveau finalement est ce qu'il
faut en finir avec le nucléaire oui ou
non gilles lazar et ni
écoutés nous au p5 notre notre objectif
si vous voulez c'est de penser au futur
on y pense déjà depuis très longtemps
moi personnellement j'y pense depuis une
dizaine d'années c'est la raison pour
laquelle j'ai créé l'om peut l'om pe
c'est une ong
qui qui prend des innovations
technologiques et écologiques justement
pour le futur et pour nos jeunes pour
préserver l'avenir de nos enfants
dans l'ump -qui est une boîte à outils
géante vous avez par exemple des
absorbeurs de co2 pour lutter justement
contre le réchauffement climatique
c'est un c'est une notion que j'avais
échangés avec monsieur jean jouzel du
geiq lorsque je l'avais rencontré à nice
il ya quelques temps
personne ne parle de ce sujet on se
demande pourquoi il faut savoir que moi
j'ai proposé avec toute mon équipe on a
proposé depuis des années nos différents
projets écologiques à la fois à l'état
français à la commission européenne et
également au pmu -qui la branche
environnemental de l'onu en étant
rejetée à chaque fois donc moi je me
posais la question est ce que est ce
qu'il ya deux poids deux mesures et est
ce que dans les discours il n'y a pas
des faux semblants et quelque part des
mensonges qui sont dits par nos
politiques ça c'est le premier point par
rapport au nucléaire si vous voulez bien
évidemment moi je pense que on avait un
avantage concurrentiel évident sur ce
sur cette énergie là je pense que le
travail n'a pas été suffisamment
approfondie au niveau scientifique
sur nos centrales et qu'il faut
peut-être imaginer effectivement des
mini centrales nucléaires c'est
peut-être une des rares fois où je
rejoins monsieur macro sur sur un de ces
thèmes là
et je pense qu'il faut qu'il faut
imaginer pour 2025 et 2030 du nucléaire
un petit peu plus durables et
renouvelables
moi j je suis informaticien de formation
et je sais pertinemment que quand on
cherche on trouve vous parliez des
minicentrales c'est vrai qu emmanuel
macron qui lui à récemment fermer
fessenheim devrait annoncer
prochainement la création ces mini
centrale nucléaire dc mère née des
réacteur modulaire nouvelle génération
censés être plus économique et plus
écologique qui viendrait donc en appoint
des centrales classiques voyez ce qu'on
a dit eric ciotti
emmanuel macron fossoyeur du nucléaire
français avec la fermeture de fessenheim
la production d'électricité d'origine
nucléaire a baissé de 12 % en 2020 et la
france est dépassée par la chine le
nucléaire représente 67 % de notre
électricité par la plus faible depuis
1985 georges kiejman aux vives que c'est
là le signe qu emmanuel macron se serait
trompée ou pour relancer des mini
centrales nucléaires
non mais là je suis d'accord
avec moi aussi avec mais
pour bien comprendre de quoi on parle il
faut voir ce que ce qu'on fait du côté
du rhin en allemagne les allemands ont
arrêté le nucléaire et se lancer dans
les énergies dites renouvelables qui le
sont assez peu fiers et ils ont investi
324 milliards d'euros en quinze ans les
allemands fait les choses sérieusement
résultat des courses les ont rouvert des
centrales au charbon pire à la limite
qui polluent jusqu'à paris et vienne
contre tous les accords internes à
l'union européenne d'avoir
l'autorisation par joe biden de terminer
nord stream 2 ce qui veut dire que le
gaz russe leur sera amené directement en
contournant la pologne et l'ukraine ils
ont l'énergie l'industrie la plus
carbonées d'une européenne et ils ont
pourtant 15% de verre les grün on voit
bien que cette politique là est un échec
total et en plus comme ça a été dit il
achète du nucléaire à la france donc
bien évidemment que le nucléaire est
nécessaire points et de toute façon
c'est ce qui est écrit dans les rapports
du giec de manière claire pour comme
seul moyen réaliste
de lutter efficacement contre le
réchauffement climatique maintenant
emmanuel macron à continuer une
politique de sabordement de l'industrie
nucléaire française
d'abord c'est une cc c'est quand même un
système sont des systèmes technologiques
de pointe stratégiques qui peuvent être
dangereux donc ça aucun sens de
d'avoir de la sous traitance dans dans
le nucléaire peut pas avoir des
entreprises extérieures qui font des
soudures dans les dents dans les cuves
nucléaire ça juste aucun sens pourtant
c'est ce qui arrive nous avons aussi
des partis politiques au pouvoir qui ont
considéré que le nucléaire est une
variable d'ajustement pour pour faire
plaisir un peu à un électorat bobo dix
écologistes
résultat on n'a pas fait les
investissements nécessaires
en 2015 on a arrêté la coopération sur
ce sujet avec la chine en la chine vient
d'ouvrir la première centrale nucléaire
beaucoup plus propre au thorium
thorium qui pour nous serait plus
intéressant puisqu'on a des centrales on
a des mines de thorium en france en
particulier en bretagne pas besoin
d'aller chercher l'uranium ou si loin
comment on fait maintenant par exemple à
arlit en afrique du nord
on avait le projet astrid j'en ai parlé
tout à l'heure ça a été arrêté par
emmanuel macron le projet astrid
consiste à faire des centrales
nucléaires de quatrième génération
fonctionnant sur les déchets nucléaires
ça ça a été arrêté également bref il
faut avoir une politique sérieuse
stratégique pour le sur le nucléaire
d'investissement à long terme
sur voilà sur 20 30 ans et dans ce cadre
là il est intéressant d'avoir des mini
centrales nucléaires d'appoint mais
également qu'ils pourraient être vendues
à l'étranger car avec cette mauvaise
politique par rapport au nucléaire c'est
la russie qui nous a largement supplanté
dans le commerce international de
centrale nucléaire jean lasar in une
réaction au bouclier tarifaire qui a été
annoncé par jean castex la semaine
dernière pour justement aider les
français sur à payer leurs factures
d'énergie on va écouter ce qu'on a dit
xavier bertrand regarder
il y en a marre de l'heure comme il y en
a marre ça fait depuis le début de
l'année que les prix augmentent c'est
seulement maintenant qu'il se réveille
parce qu'on est à six mois de l'élection
présidentielle
ils nous prennent pour des imbéciles
moi j'aurais rendu l'argent alors ça
pose évidemment la question des taxes
sur l'énergie 1 c'est ce dont il s'agit
dans la bouche de xavier bertrand est ce
que vous êtes d'accord avec lui est ce
que les taxons sont beaucoup trop élevés
ce qu'il aurait fallu être un peu plus
généreux vu les circonstances
alors moi j'ai un point de vue un petit
peu plus générale sur votre question je
trouve que je trouve que en europe et
particulièrement en france on a une
tendance à être spectateur plus qu
acteur et il a utilisé très rapidement
les dédommagements les aides des aides
financières
on a pu le voir avec ligier les jeunes
où l'état français a donné une enveloppe
de 17 milliards on a pu le voir avec
l'aviation ou bruno le maire s'est
empressé il ya quelques il ya quelques
temps de donner 15 milliards est
également sur la crise du coup vide qui
nous a coûté plus de 150 milliards donc
si vous voulez on à la tête de l'état un
banquier qui qui pensent résoudre toutes
les problématiques avec des aides
financières et des bons en fait puisque
ça ressemble un petit peu a des bons de
l'ancienne guerre
moi je ne partage pas tout à fait cette
manière de procéder je pense qu'il faut
élever la france
et l'amener à une position d'acteur
privilégié justement profiter de cette
problématique environnementale et de
réchauffement climatique puisque c'est
le sujet quand même malgré tout de votre
émission et il faut savoir que c'est
plus qu'une urgence c'est à dire que
évidemment il faut conserver le
nucléaire et l'améliorer mon confrère a
raison mais ce que je veux dire
également c'est qu'il faut développer
les énergies renouvelables et être y
être le plus souvent possible de manière
à avoir un avantage concurrentiel et
pourquoi pas comment le préconise au p5
revendre ensuite nos solutions à
l'europe et au reste du monde et là à ce
moment là on pourra en fait
effectivement faire de l'argent est ce
que vous êtes d'accord avec salle
georges kiejman au violon on donne on
donne beaucoup d'heures effectivement
aux français et on taxe dans le même
temps donc est ce que il n'y aurait pas
là une solution plus plus pérenne à
avoir en matière de taxation énergétique
mais sur le fond je suis d'accord et
monsieur lazhar est ni un gros
il s'en va construire joint c'est ce que
je vous ai dit tout à l'heure c'est une
politique de la balle qu'il faut mettre
en oeuvre et pas à réagir
vous n'allez pas voir les choses par le
petit bout de la lorgnette et et réagir
comme on le fait trop souvent en
particulier au moment des élections en
ce moment monsieur emmanuel macron quand
il est en train de distribuer d'argent
et
il serait je ne pense pas que les les
électeurs soient aussi stupides qu'ils
le croient et qu'ils pensent que cela va
durer et si d'aventuré il était réélu
donc bien évidemment que ce qui sera
éventuellement donner
dans cette période électorale sera
immédiatement repris par d'autres formes
de taxes ou l'arrêt d'un coup de pouce
qui tombe bien bien à propos souvenez il
avait fait la même chose avec au moment
des régionales ça a été le
celtic et où culture pour les jeunes
c'est 300 400 euros donnés aux jeunes
juste avant l'élection bon là ça passe
là c'est sûr c'est sur l'énergie et
parce qu'il se trouve bien embarrassé
avec cette augmentation
donc non je la france est une grande
puissance il faut qu'elle reprenne son
rang et arrêter de fonctionner comme si
nous étions une nation écrasé appauvri
et qui distribue les bons et des coupons
assez à ses citoyens c'est pas sérieux
je les ai eu une dernière question on
est bon élève en matière d'émissions de
gaz à effet de serre le 1er janvier
prochain les véhicules qui émettent
un certain seuil de gaz à effet de serre
vont être davantage taxés on sait que ce
sont pas les plus riches qui ont des
véhicules polluants ma question c'est
comment on est bons élèves pourquoi
aller si vite dans ces réformes est ce
qu'on peut pas attendre finalement
alors est-ce qu'on peut pas attendre non
je pense pas parce que il faut quand
même savoir que même si on est bons
élèves comme vous dites
la pollution de l'air en france
comment ils à cause de décès prématuré
sur un nombre qui quittent qui avait été
imaginé à 50 mille décès par an et qui
finalement a été corrigé à cent mille
décès par an donc on est quand même
on a quand même des véhicules polluants
et je pense que nicolas hulot d'ailleurs
le disait également en son temps c'est
une problématique
mais là encore on est sur un
solutionnement de banquiers c'est à dire
avec des taxations et et des leviers
financiers moi personnellement je ne
pense pas que la solution se soit
d'attaqué portefeuilles des citoyens
effectivement le monde le monde de la
voiture et un monde complètement injuste
par rapport justement à l'équité et la
justice sociale c'est à dire que vous le
savez bien tout le monde prêt payent le
même prix de litres de carburant tout le
monde paie le même prix aux péages etc
donc
non la solution la solution n'est pas du
tout financières à mon sens et il
faudrait il faudrait plutôt se
concentrer sur le développement de
technologies de moteurs à l'hydrogène ou
ou deux moteurs électriques mais avec
des solutions pérennes sur l'électricité
et sur comment le traitement des
batteries usagées et c'est donc c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous on paie 5 on
pense vraiment qu'il faut créer une
boîte à outils nationale comme l'om peut
par exemple qui a débuté il ya huit ans
déjà
qui serait en fait
une énorme solution avec à l'intérieur
des mini solutions comme des moteurs à
hydrogène et ces mecs beaucoup
malheureusement il nous reste plus temps
très très court george friedman au d26
nous reste 10 mondial et scope mère
plutôt qu'à on peut faire beaucoup de
choses mais une des choses à faire c'est
par exemple arrêter de vendre le bois
brut à la chine qui protège ses forêts
ce qui se passe c'est un petit exemple
mais colossal on envoie notre bois brut
ont détruit une forêt en chine donc
c'est on daigne assez peu parce que
c'est de la matière
brute et les chinois nous renvoie du
bois transformé en meubles outils et
qu'on achète cinq fois plus cher que ce
que le bois brut ou on a vendu et dans
l'est il faut transporter tout ça en
bateau et on reparlera évidemment pas ce
moment c'est pas ça pose aussi la
question avait un display la
réindustrialisation de la france
effectivement on n'a pas le temps d'en
parler malheureusement ce sera l'objet
d'un autre débat agite lazarini merci
beaucoup pour votre participation à ce
débat merci georges kiejman hollidge je
rappelle que vous êtes tous les deux
candidats à l'élection présidentielle
officiellement déclaré merci